- So Ben, as you know, is
a world renowned expert
on the crimes committed
by the Khmer Rouge.
He's the A. Whitney Griswold
Professor of History
and Founding Director of
the Genocide Studies Program
here at Yale.
He's the author of the classics.
How Pol Pot Came to Power.
The Pol Pot Regime, Blood and Soil,
Genocide and Resistance in Southeast Asia.
And the important recent book,
Viet Nam: A History From
Earliest Times to the Present.
I think one of the most important
distinctions that Ben has
is if you wanna get his books for cheap,
you just go to Pham Ngu Lao in Saigon,
and they're all on
mimeographed and available
in very expert reproductions, right?
So sorry, Yale University Press.
But it's kind of a mark of
having made it in the world
when people are bootlegging
your books, I think.
I haven't reached that fame yet,
but I'm looking forward to
someday learning from Ben,
how to get that done.
Anyhow and Eve Zucker has
been a visiting professor
in anthropology here at Yale.
She's a member of
the Steering Committee for the
Yale Genocide Studies Program
and current president of the
Center for Khmer Studies.
Her books include
Forest of Struggle:
Moralities of Remembrance
in Upland Cambodia.
Mass Violence and Memory
in the Digital Age,
and Coexistence in the
Aftermath of Mass Violence.
And of course the book
we'll be talking about today as well.
It's not always the case that historians
and anthropologists collaborate well,
but this is a really exciting example
where the convergence
of an important topic
has brought together Ben and Eve
and also many of our students here at Yale
and other scholars around the world
to come together for this important book.
So I wanna say one last thing is this book
is a result of a conference
and workshop put on
here at Yale in November of 2018.
So I just wanna thank them for bringing
so many important people to
do work on this topic here.
So please join me in welcoming
Ben Kiernan and Eve Zucker
to talk about the book.
(audience clapping)
- We would like to thank
Erik Harms and Kris Mooseker
and the Council of Southeast Asian Studies
and all of you for being here today,
both online and in person,
which is pretty exciting.
And we also would like
to thank the contributors
to the book who are...
Some of them are here
today, but not all of them
who made this project what it is.
So I'm just gonna go move
over to start the PowerPoint.
I'm gonna (indistinct).
So what is the book about?
the book is a thematic
and historical examination
of the causes and the
consequences of violence
in Southeast Asia.
Particularly between the
periods of 1945, up to 2020,
when the book was published.
And covers six cases,
Cambodia, Thailand, Indonesia
Myanmar, The Philippines and Vietnam.
And as you can see here,
we had 18 contributing
authors to the volume.
Which are listed here.
There's quite a few of them.
So we thought we'd just list them for you.
And we'll be talking a little
bit more about the book,
but I just wanna move
ahead a little bit now
to the next...
To talk about how the book started.
So this project really started
from a few different reasons.
One of them was that Ben
has been teaching courses
on Southeast Asia forever.
Maybe not forever, but for a long time.
And I was teaching
courses on Southeast Asia
and particularly on
violence in Southeast Asia.
And one of the things that we noticed...
Sorry, can everyone understand me online?
Is it clear?
Okay.
So one of the things
that we noticed was that
there's not a lot of
anthologies that cover violence
of the region in Southeast Asia.
The ones that do exist many
are like 10 years old or so.
And a lot of them aren't
specifically about mass violence,
some focused just on the Cold War.
Which that's a fairly recent one,
but other ones also focus on terrorism.
Like the one by Damien Kingsbury.
And there's some good ones,
but they'll often only
included a few countries.
So we thought there was
a need for something.
For something that covered
the region as a whole
on this subject.
So that was one thing.
Another thing that we noticed is that
there's a lot of new scholarship going on.
And not only new scholarship
with new scholars
and young and upcoming scholars,
but also very new topics that
really haven't been covered
before in the past.
And that was really exciting.
So that was another
impetus for the project.
And the other major thing
that was going on at the time,
which I'll go over it a little
more detail in just a minute
was what was going on in
the world at the time.
If we think about it, it's
a little different now,
but back in 2018, as crazy as it is now,
it was pretty crazy then.
So you have this
authoritarianism on the rise,
you have populism on the rise,
and this was pretty
much all over the world.
You know, we had Trump,
you had Putin, you had Xi
and so forth.
But in Southeast Asia,
you also had the same thing happening,
particularly with Duterte
in the Philippines,
and also Hun Sen.
And there was also a lot
of impunity of leaders.
They were pretty much
doing what they wanted,
with no consequences at the time.
And a lot of intolerance for difference.
Different ideas, different
types of people and so forth.
So to Zoom in a little bit,
and to get a snapshot of that.
We see that during that
period you had in Myanmar,
the Rohingya Genocide taking place,
which had been ongoing since 2016.
You also had the tens
of thousands of Rohingya
being murdered in their
villages which were being burned
and other mass executions and so forth.
And by 2018, there were
also 730,000 refugees
already in Bangladesh who
were fleeing for their lives.
A lot of them were also
fleeing not to Bangladesh,
but also out on boats
and so forth to Malaysia.
But it was a real crisis taking place.
The crisis continues, but it
was pretty severe then as well.
You had mass imprisonments
in the concentration camps
of the Rohingya.
And finally in August of 2018,
you had the UNHCR declare
that the generals of the army
should actually be held
accountable for genocide.
So that was Myanmar.
A little bit about it.
In Thailand, you had two
coups over a very short time.
You had demonstrations taking place.
Which had been ongoing for a while.
You had again...
You see the impunity of the leaders.
There's violence in the south
there's violence against
political opponents.
There's surveillance happening
online, and Facebook.
Also though people didn't
feel safe in other places
about what they said.
There was numerous arrests.
Sometimes for as long as up to 10 years
for crimes, like saying
something about the monarchy.
Turning now to Cambodia,
you had the national election
that took place that year in July.
And that was another volatile situation.
You had a lot of discomfort at the time
amongst the population who feared
that there were being surveyed.
Even in coffee shops.
There was surveillance also online.
And there were good reasons
for them to be worried.
Because in 2016, the activist
Kem Lay was assassinated.
And then you also had
the opposition leader
right before the elections,
Kem Sokha he was arrested
and several other
members of the opposition
were not allowed to
participate in elections.
Also in Cambodia that same year,
you had Case 02 happening
of the Khmer Rouge Tribunal.
That was with Nuon Chea and Khieu Samphan.
And on November of that year,
which was actually a week
after our conference,
the ECC found Nuon Chea guilty of genocide
against both ethnic
Chams and the Vietnamese.
And Khieu Samphan guilty of genocide
against the Vietnamese.
And both guilty of
crimes against humanity,
including of extermination.
So that was a huge deal at the time.
That they actually passed down
those sentences of genocide.
And also those crimes against humanity.
In the Philippines, the
war on drugs continued
and showed no sign of letting up.
In fact, Duterte stated
that he had no intentions
of slowing that down or stopping it.
The same year you had Derek Duterte
pull out of the International
Criminal Court, the ICC.
In a blatant statement of disregard
for any of its principles.
And that was the year also Maria Ressa,
who recently won the Nobel Prize.
Who is also the founder of
the news outlet Rappler.
She was arrested also during that time.
And so with all of that happening,
just in that one year,
that was the context
where we decided to have the conference.
And that was what it
was on everybody's mind
when we had the conference
was this keen awareness of
the atmosphere in the world
and what was happening.
And so the keynote for that conference,
we had Jeffrey Robinson
who spoke about Indonesia.
That was on the first evening.
We had 24 participants in all
representing several different countries.
And we also, at the end,
we had Al McCoy gave a
wonderful talk at the end,
which wrapped up all the papers.
And he provided some great insights
into how the different
pieces come together.
And that was on the last day.
And we appreciate the support of course,
that we got from the council
of Southeast Asian studies
and the Yale Genocide Studies Program
and other parts of the
Yale MacMillan Center
and so forth for providing us sponsorship
for that conference.
And also of course, the New
York Southeast Asia Network,
which was our primary
funder for that event.
So with this, this conference
was really the basis for the
volume and was the papers
that came out of it that
were presented on that day.
So just going now for
a moment to the context
of where our book starts,
and that would be just
in the post-World War II.
Immediate post World War II.
So in 1945, on August
6th, you had a US aircraft
a B-29 drop the atomic bomb onto Hiroshima
thereby ending the war.
And also basically signaling
the start of the Cold War
and a new world order.
And so this ends up having
immense consequences
for Southeast Asia and the world.
But in Southeast Asia,
because it meant that Japanese withdrawal
from Southeast Asia.
And so the end of all the brutality
that they brought with
them to Southeast Asia.
But it also left a little
bit of a vacuum there
for a brief period of time.
The colonial powers were fun.
Some of them would end up coming back.
But there was an opportunity
there for things to change
and for things to happen.
It was one of those chaotic
periods that Alfred Lau
called a meltdown essentially.
That was the context.
And so what happened then?
So there was this
opportunity for independence
that was there.
And with that opportunity
for independence,
then nations had to start
imagining what type of nation
would they want to have.
And so now there were
these different systems
and different ideologies
that they could draw
influence from potentially.
There was communism coming from
China and the Soviet Union,
and you had also American capitalism,
which provided another
thought form of thinking
and form of organization.
So this was the context.
And I'm gonna stop right
there and turn it over to Ben
who's gonna talk about the connections,
the historical connections
between these different countries.
And then later we'll come back
and I'll talk about some of the things.
- Thank you very much Eve.
I'd also like to thank
the Council on Southeast Asia Studies.
(Ben coughs)
Excuse me.
As well as the MacMillan Center
and the Genocide Studies Program.
And the Orvile Schell
Center at the law school
for the support for this project,
which has been a pleasure to work with Eve
on the final book project,
as well as the conference.
As Eve said, she zoomed in
on the actual events of 2018
when the conference was
held and the actual coverage
of the various topics in the book.
I'd like to zoom back
out again temporarily,
just for a while and look
at not so much at the content of the book,
but the context of the events
that we cover in the book.
The much larger context,
looking back at the early
modern period in Southeast Asia.
And some of the bigger themes
of violence in Southeast Asia,
as well as the chronological context
and the thematic...
Not just thematic, but chronological,
and the causation of mass
violence in Southeast Asia,
I've recently had an exchange in print
with Yehuda Bauer, the eminent
historian of the Holocaust
in which he looked back at his work
over many, many decades on the Holocaust.
And he thought about
the presence of the
Jewish people in Europe
and the importance,
maybe he thought about the importance
of the issue of migration
as a long-term issue in the history
of the fate of the Jewish people.
And I thought about
that in our discussions.
And what can that tell us
about the history of mass
violence in Southeast Asia?
Because Southeast Asia,
unlike China and India
is a predominantly maritime world region.
Like Mediterranean Europe
and Asian Mediterranean,
perhaps comprising, large
archipelagos and long coastlines.
And as many of you know,
the leading historians of
the Southeast Asian region
consider Southeast Asia
to be a crossroads.
Anthony Reid subtitled, his 2015
History of Southeast
Asia: Critical Crossroads.
And in his 1971 book,
Vietnam and the Chinese Model
Alexander Woodside wrote
"If mainland Southeast Asia
was a crossroad of civilizations,
'the Europe of Asia' in its juxtaposition
of competing cultures and societies.
Traditional Vietnam was a
crossroad within this crossroad.
Especially after it has
seized the Mekong Delta.
The sum of all the political
difficulties," he concludes.
"And the cultural
tensions was tremendous."
Now Southeast Asia's earliest
documented cases of genocide
involved ethnic groups
migrating along the coast
or from the interior to the coast
or encountering new religious movements
arriving in the region by sea.
Along the Eastern coast of
mainland Southeast Asia,
the Vietnamese southward expansion
and the genocide of Chams in 1471 to 1509
were followed by Cambodian
massacres of ethnic Vietnamese
who had subsequently
migrated down the coast
into the Mekong Delta.
French missionaries reported
that the Cambodian attack
on the Vietnamese control
of Ha Tinh in 1731,
had "made an enormous carnage of them.
They counted more than
10,000 of them lost."
Afterwards, "They killed
all those Vietnamese
that they found in Cambodia,
men, women, and children."
Then in 1750 Cambodia's Monarch
gave orders or permission,
the missionaries wrote,
to massacre all the
Vietnamese who could be found.
And this order was executed
very precisely and very cruely.
This massacre lasted a month and a half,
only about 20 women and
children were spared.
The massacre was general
from Kahlon to Ha Tinh.
The Vietnamese kingdom in turn
resorted to similar measures in the 1830s,
when it conducted systematic
massacres of Cambodians
in an attempt to colonize their country.
In Southeast Asia's Western mainland,
Burmans expanded south to the coast.
Then the home of the Mon people.
In 1740 Mons killed 7,000 Burmans
in a genocidal massacre
in the Port of Syria.
In 1757, conquering Burman forces
massacred thousands of
Mons in their port of Pegu.
And then on the island of Java in 1648,
the ruler of the kingdom of Matara
slaughtered 5,000 Islamic teachers
and members of their families.
Now despite sharing
some common (indistinct)
historical features like migration,
these cases, nevertheless
proved to be scattered.
Relatively infrequent
outbreaks over five centuries
of Southeast Asian history.
Otherwise, I think it's still true to say
the region is indeed
a cosmopolitan crossroads
of civilizations.
Remarkable for harboring nearly
all the world's religions,
Budhism, Hinduism, Islam, Christianity,
and Confucianism are all
prominent in Southeast Asia.
So we have a major theme of migration,
perhaps that underlies
outbreaks of mass violence.
But these are not really
connected to one another.
They're scattered outbreaks
over a long period of time.
But there are some perhaps big themes.
What we have by contrast
in the cases that we look at in this book,
in the post 1945 period,
much closer connections between the cases.
Not just big themes, but
closely related cases.
And that's what I want to look at now.
To Zoom back in at the
cases that we cover.
Particularly in the post-war period.
Katie Munyan from the
Schell Center, formerly of
the Schell Center for
International Human Rights.
And the law school has a
very interesting chapter
on intent as a element of genocide.
She starts off with the legal explanation
of what intent means as
a component of genocide.
Not just general intent,
meaning the action must be
deliberate, not accidental.
But also specific intent,
meaning the importance that
the action must be done
in order to destroy a group as such.
It must be carried out
consciously desiring
the distraction of the group as such.
That's very important with genocide.
Not necessarily with
crimes against humanity,
such as extermination, or even
(indistinct) mass violence,
or even let alone political
violence, which we also cover.
But she does say that
these cases of intent
can be seen from a distance
and they could be judged as coming from
by nonjudicial observers.
And she points out that in
a number of these cases,
intent was pretty clear.
Even though it was not
accurate to say from a distance
or while the cases were taking place,
that the perpetrators were
already criminally liable.
Because it hadn't been judged by a court.
But a nonjudicial authority
or observer or NGO
studying these events could state
that the intent was observable
and could have said much
earlier than they did
that there was a case for genocide,
let alone other examples
of crimes against humanity
like extermination or political violence.
And she's critical.
I think quite accurately
of many of the observers
for being hesitant in pointing out
where there was a case
for an investigation
or a criminal trial.
Which would decide whether
or not these perpetrators
were criminally liable.
And this is one feature
I think, of these cases
that connect a number of
the cases that we looked at.
That there was a delay in the suppression
or the intervention in these
cases in Southeast Asia.
I'll just give you one
example of where I think
there could have been
much quicker recognition
of the possible intent.
Eve has mentioned Nuon
Chea and Khieu Samphan
who were found guilty in
2018 of genocide in Cambodia.
Nuon Chea was found guilty of the genocide
of the Cham Muslim minority in Cambodia.
And the Pol Pot regime
of which he was the
number two was in power
from 1975 to 1979.
The only foreign head of
state to visit Cambodia
during that period, when the
Pol Pot regime was in power,
was Ne Win, the military
dictator of Burma.
He visited in November, 1977,
just after Pol Pot's
triumphant visit to China
in which he came out as the real leader
of the Democratic Kampuchea,
the Pol Pot Regime.
He had just returned back
to Cambodia, triumphantly.
He didn't meet with Ne Win publicly.
We don't know whether they
actually met privately.
But Ne Win, the only foreign head of state
to visit Democratic
Kampuchea in the four years
it was in power.
He met four times with Nuon Chea.
He met four times with Khieu
Samphan, the two officials,
the head of state of
Cambodia Khieu Samphan.
If he didn't meet with Pol Pot,
perhaps Pol Pot was too
busy unlocking his suitcases
after coming back from China.
He probably had a lot
of (indistinct) suits
that he had to unpack.
But he met four times with Nuon Chea
and four times with Khieu Samphan.
If he didn't meet secretly with Pol Pot,
I'll be a monkey's uncle.
But anyway the genocide
of the Cham Muslims
was well underway when Nuon Chea
was later found guilty of it.
Nuon Chea in November,
1977, returned to Burma.
And in February of 1978, just weeks later,
a couple of months later.
Operation Naga Min in Burma.
Which was a massive
discrimination and persecution
of the Rohingya Muslims.
The first of its kind in Burma.
By may of 1978, 250,000,
I believe, Rohingya's
had fled into Bangladesh, and
many of them had been killed
while they were fleeing
by the Ne Win military dictatorship.
If Ne Win had not discussed
with Nuon Chea and Khieu Samphan
the persecution of the
Cham Muslims in Cambodia,
just weeks before.
Again I'll be a monkey's uncle,
in the four meetings that
he had with Nuon Chea.
Then again, of course, in 1991 and '92,
a second campaign began in Burma.
Of persecution of the Rohingya Muslims,
and then two more waves
ending in genocide in 2018.
But it wasn't until much
later that foreign observers
began to call for
investigation of genocide
against the Rohingyas
in Burma, decades later.
Really the Katie Munyan
has this all documented.
How hesitant international observers were
to identify this as an
ongoing potential genocide.
There was talk of ethnic cleansing,
which is not an international crime,
but gained recognition in
the Balkan case in the 1990s.
There were all kinds of other terms
applied to what was
happening to the Rohingyas.
But had it happened to the
Cham Muslims in the 1970s.
And Ne Win had visited Cambodia
and gone back to Burma
to implement something that had turned out
to be very similar.
So there's a connection
that I don't think has been detected,
or certainly not enough made
of it between these two cases
that we cover in this book.
Thailand was never colonized,
by the Western powers in Southeast Asia.
It was the only country like Ethiopia.
In Africa it was the only
country in Southeast Asia
that was not colonized.
However, it didn't escape
the post-war violence
as Eve has pointed out.
That the other countries of Southeast Asia
were subjected to.
Indeed Thailand was drawn deeply
into the massive waves
of post-war violence
that affected Southeast Asia.
Three quarters of the bombing
raids over north Vietnam
were by planes that took off
from air bases in Thailand.
And this had something to do
with violence within Thailand,
as well as the former
foreign minister of Thailand.
Thanat Khoman later complained
the civilians like himself,
a foreign minister.
He said didn't even know
that the Thai military were building
these new bases in Thailand.
Was only later they found out
that the United States bases
that were used for the
bombing of North Vietnam
were being built.
The civilians, although in the government
in the cabinet were not informed.
Thailand also said 25
battalions of special forces
to participate in the secret war in Laos.
So Thailand was drawn in
to these international
campaigns of violence
that it had managed to escape
in the colonial period before 1945.
Another example of the connections
is a country that managed
to keep out the war
under the reign of Prince
Sihanouk in Cambodia
was Prince Sihanouk, he
managed to do that partly
by his Alliance with China.
He maintained a neutral
foreign policy for Cambodia
during the 1960s.
And he saw China as a
mentor or a figure of power
that guaranteed his
neutrality in the Cold War.
He visited China in October of 1965
for its National Day October 1st.
What he didn't know was when
he went to pay homage to China,
Pol Pot was there on the same day,
secretly visiting China.
Pol Pot the secret head of the
communist party of Kampuchea,
the underground opposition
to Prince Sihanouk.
The Chinese and Pol Pot himself
kept the secret from Prince Sihanouk.
The head of state of Cambodia.
The two Cambodians were there,
but only Pol Pot knew
that the other party Sihanouk was there.
Now, what else happened
on October 1st, 1965,
the coup in Indonesia.
Which was also covered by Jeffrey
Robinson's opening chapter
in our book.
What was important for
Cambodia was the mass slaughter
of the Indonesian communist
party that began on that day.
October 1st China's National
Day by accident, I'm sure.
But the importance of it
was, Pol Pot later said it
in 1977 in a retrospective history
of the communist movement in (indistinct).
If we hadn't been in that
position, the same position
of the communist in Indonesia.
That is an unarmed, relatively
peaceful communist movement,
we he would have been in greater danger
than the communists in Indonesia.
But we weren't, we decided
that we wouldn't do that.
We would stage a rebellion
against Sihanouk's regime,
which they later did.
They were looking at the
communists a disastrous experience
in Indonesia on October
1st and afterwards in 1965.
And so the Pol Pot decided
that he wasn't gonna put himself in danger
of what happened to the
communists in Indonesia.
Instead he was gonna do that exactly,
to his opponents in Cambodia,
which he did when he
came to power in 1975.
Another example of the connections
between the Southeast Asian countries
that we cover in this book
that they contributors cover very well,
I think is the connections
between countries
that are not usually linked.
Malaya, The Philippines and South Vietnam.
Now these connections existed,
political connections,
but they also show how
different these countries are.
The Philippines became
independent in 1946.
It was immediately struck by
an agrarian communist
revolution or a revolt
by the Huk agrarian rebels.
And it took place in Central Luzon.
And one of the people who took part
in the successful defeat of that rebellion
as an advisor to president
Magsaysay was Edward Lansdale.
Colonel Edward Lansdale.
Who helped design with
Magsaysay's reforms,
some agrarian reforms that
managed to undercut the appeal
of the Huk Rebels in Central Luzon
and bring that rebellion to an end.
Later when the insurgency
in South Vietnam gathered force
Lansdale was transferred to south Vietnam.
And took a position as an advisor
to President Ngo Dinh Diem
of South Vietnam.
And became an important...
I think he opened the second...
There were two CIA stations
in South Vietnam in 1954.
Meanwhile, in Malaya
the British had held on,
unlike in the Americans
in the Philippines,
held on to their colony in
Malaya, as late as 1957.
They have been similar,
to a Malayan coming
to start a rebellion from 1948.
And the British had fought that rebellion
in what was called The Emergency,
the Malayan Emergency.
And one of the British
advisors, military advisers
who helped the British
put down The Emergency,
the Malayan communist party revolt was...
What was this name?
I've forgotten his name right now?
But he was a key figure
in the British successful
cabin insurgency.
He was later transferred to-
(indistinct chatter)
Sorry.
- I think the last name was Thompson.
He was part of an-
- Thompson, Sir. Robert
Thompson, thanks Michelle.
Sir. Robert Thompson was later transferred
to South Vietnam at the advice of
Tunku Abdul Rahman the
Prime Minister of Malaya
after independence in 1957.
And he was then made such an
impression on Ngo Dinh Diem,
that Diem asked the British government
to send him back to South Vietnam
as head of the British
Military Advisory Mission.
And he went back to South
Vietnam and according to the CIA.
CIA head, George Carver,
Sir. Robert Thompson and
Ngo Dinh Diem together
devised the Strategic Hamlet
Program in South Vietnam.
Now they've been very
successful, the British in Malaya
in undercutting the insurgency there.
And the Americans and Magsaysay
have been very successful
in undercutting the
insurgency in the Philippines
with those two experiences
were successful.
But in South Vietnam, they weren't.
The Strategic Hamlets where a failure,
the NLF or Viet Cong insurgency
grew larger and larger.
And eventually was nearly
successful in 1965.
At the time the Americans intervened
with ground troops in 1965.
Why was that not the case like it was
in the Philippines and Malaya?
Because South Vietnam was
a very different society
than those two countries.
The insurgency was quite circumscribed
in both Malaya and the Philippines.
Regionalized or ethnically
circumscribed in Malaya.
Whereas in South Vietnam
land inequalities were great,
not only in the Mekong Delta.
But also along the Southern
and central Vietnamese coast.
And the Strategic Hamlet Program
had to be much larger and more unpopular
and eventually failed.
So South Vietnam was
quite a different society
than the Philippines and Malaya.
So although the connections existed
between those countries and the strategies
that were adopted were quite similar,
they failed in South Vietnam
because of the different societies there.
There is also a difference
in the countries
that experienced violence
after World War II,
and those that didn't.
Burma and Indonesia, for instance,
particularly in the 1950s,
experienced democratic
flourishing, in the 1950s.
So under Sukarno in
Indonesia and U Nu in Burma.
Despite the challenge of a Korean revolt
and a communist revolt in Burma.
Both starting in 1948,
Burma was a successful
democracy until the overthrow
by the military under Ne Win in 1962.
Similarly Indonesia was
a multi-party democracy
until around 1958, when Sukarno
instituted what we call
a guided democracy,
which shaded into the
military takeover of 1965.
But those two examples in the
1950s show that Southeast Asia
its largest country on the mainland,
at least geographically was Burma.
And in Indonesia, the largest
country in Southeast Asia
didn't have the experience
of at least temporarily
successful democracy.
And that is now the case once again,
after a long Suharto era, ending in 1998.
So we do have some examples
of heterogeneity, diversity
and of the variety of possibilities
that are in the history of
post-war Southeast Asia.
Finally, I'd like to mention the chapter
by Hoang Min Vu on Cambodia.
Which is a nice way to
sum up what I'm saying,
because it's a hard hitting
attack on all of the parties
to the Cambodian disaster.
All of the international global responses
to the genocide in Cambodia
come in for a fierce criticism
on the part of Hoang Minh Vu.
It's worth reading,
I think because he is unstinting
in his critique of Vietnam,
of Asyan, of the United States, of China.
And he ends with a kicker.
I'm not gonna tell you what it is,
but I suggest that you read
to the end of his chapter.
But I'll leave the rest to Eve to finish.
Thank you.
- Thank you, Ben.
Really interesting as always.
So Ben talked about some of
the historical connections
and I'm gonna go through
probably fairly quickly
some of the conceptual
thematic connections.
So how long do we actually have here?
- [Erik] We could end by 01:00
so we can make sure there's time for Q&A.
- Okay, so I will probably
go in some more in depth
and then some will go more quickly.
So there are two sets of conceptual themes
that sort of show up immediately
at the beginning of the book.
And one of them is the...
Well, they're both actually
in the introduction,
but somebody who's looking
at the book might notice
that the way things are organized
in the table of contents
are a bit different than they're discussed
earlier on in the chapters.
And there's a reason for that.
These chapters could be
organized in a multitude of ways
and can be thought of
in a multitude of ways.
And that's really part
of the goal of the book.
Is that people can look
at the different chapters,
the different cases and understand
connections between them.
Historical connections,
regional connections,
and other thematic connections.
And hopefully it's
useful then for students
and also for people teaching
about Southeast Asia or mass violence.
So we wanted to just draw
out some of those themes
that may not altogether be obvious.
Some are obvious, some
are a little bit less.
So here are some initial
themes to consider
and I'll discuss at least a couple of them
in a little more depth.
So there are social and
political transformation
during periods of change
and during periods of transformation,
as I'll discuss in a moment.
It's a very vulnerable time,
a potentially very dangerous time.
There's this ambiguity.
Ambiguity of identities,
ambiguities of intent.
Also liminality, marginality,
people who live in marginal places,
who occupy marginal places within society,
or literally on the
border or whose identities
for some reason are seen as uncertain.
There's the political imagination.
Which is not something
that's always considered,
but how people imagine the other,
how people imagine nations,
how people imagine who other people are.
This all comes into play
during these periods.
I mentioned earlier,
the impunity of leaders
and the role of leaders
and then talked quite a
bit about that as well.
And there's also the haunting
of the past and the present.
Which tends to be the enduring...
The enduring not only consequences,
but shadow of genocides and mass violence
that continues to haunt
societies in various ways.
And then just briefly which
we'll talk about in a moment,
killing as both as a technical
procedure on the one hand,
which is very different
than another type of killing
that takes place, that's
much more visceral.
And you see that in different cases.
It's a really interesting question
of why that is so and
how are they the same
and how are they different?
And that's it really,
I think actually an area to be explored
in far more depth than it has been.
So social and political transformation,
as it's been mentioned.
He talked about how in some
Southeast Asian societies
like in Indonesia,
they went from democracy to
then when Suharto comes in
and massacres hundreds
of thousands of people.
A million people or so.
That's been happening
within this transition from
democracy into a dictatorship.
And then you have other situations
whereas you have in Burma
where they move from democracy.
During that transition,
you have the violence
perpetrated against the Rohingya.
Now it's interesting in Southeast Asia
in thinking about...
Coming from my anthropological
point of view here.
When you think about Southeast
Asia about transitions,
about transformations.
In life cycle rituals or in life cycle...
During pregnancy, during
birth, during death,
it's considered a very fruitful
and yet very delicate process.
Great care must be taken
because there's a danger
in this process, when something is moving
from one state to another,
when something's coming into being.
And I think it's a useful way
of thinking about these periods also.
Of transitions of moving
towards independence,
or changing of political
systems and so forth.
There's an uncertainty there,
there's a vulnerability
there, there's a danger there.
And in this sort of context,
you end up with situations
where people feel insecure.
And then they often...
In some cases, if we saw
in Burma and so forth,
they end up finding people that...
Identifying people as imposters.
Sorry, Azeem Ibrahim
talks about this notion
of the imposter and the outsider,
but so does Elliott
Prasse-Freeman and Andrew Ong,
who talked about exclusion and
inclusion within the state.
And this theme you see
comes up quite a lot.
Certainly through all
the Myanmar readings,
but also certainly in Cambodia.
Where you had Kosal Path and Tram Luong
talking about the ethnic Vietnamese
during the Lon Nol period
who were seen as in some cases,
as demons and as the enemy
and as essentially
masking their true intent,
which the intention connects up
with Katherine Munyan's chapter.
So I'm looking, and I'm seeing
I have three minutes left.
So I'll just quickly
go through the slides.
So at least you can see where
some of the chapters sit
with some of these different themes.
So with the ambiguity and liminality,
I discuss it a bit.
It's obviously very connected to the theme
of transformation and transition.
But one of the things that
happens in these contexts
and (indistinct) talks about this as well
in terms of ethnic violence.
That there's this language
that starts occurring
at the language of the imposter
in these contexts of violence.
And this counterfeit person somehow
and counterfeit identities.
And that plays out and you see
this an Al McCoy's chapter,
where he talks about Duterte.
You have this situation where
the people being targeted
are the marginal community
of what are the so-called
drug users and dealers
who are being picked
out as, you know not...
In this case,
excluding as Elliott Prasse-Freeman
and Andrew Ong talk about.
They're some of the people
that are pushed out,
excluded from society then.
You also have the topics of
the theme of impunity, silence,
and rule of the leaders.
While silence and impunity
are obviously linked,
they also can be treated separately.
Well, silence certainly
contributes to impunity.
It also rests on its own impunity
as other sources as well.
Several of the (indistinct)
chapters talk about impunity.
Particularly though in
Tyrell Haberkon's chapter
on Thailand, and also in
Pawakapan's chapter also Thailand,
and also in Laura McGrew's chapter
who talks about the...
Who talks about Cambodia and the post war
in the 90s, 2000s era.
And the amount of impunity
that government has had there
with violence that's been perpetrated
since the Khmer Rouge by the state.
Just quickly I'll just share this one
technical versus visceral violence.
So by technical violence,
what's meant here is violence
that's very much removed from the person.
For example, the aerial bombings
that Sophie Quinn Judge
talks about in her chapter,
in Vietnam, by the US or the
aerial bombings in Vietnam,
during the first Indochinese war.
Talked about in Christian Lentz's chapter
In Daniel Bultmann's chapter,
which takes place in the prison
and torture center of Tuol Sleng.
It's a very kind of different type
of technical violence there.
The body is very much involved,
but not involved in the
kind of intimate way
with the visceral violence.
Instead, the bodies are
treated as mere resources.
So they're harvested for blood.
They're harvested for bile.
The gallbladders are
removed, all to sort of serve
the purposes of the revolution
of the Khmer Rouge purpose.
And so there you have...
It's very clinical.
So there's these medical
experiments on the one hand,
but on the other hand, it's
kind of like factory farming
in a sense on the other.
That the bodies are just simply processed.
Visceral several chapters cover that.
And let's see.
Since we're out of time.
There is the political imagination,
which I mentioned little bit earlier.
And this has to do with
cruising several chapters
of how people are imagining
themselves as citizens
or how they imagine
citizenship altogether.
How the nation is imagined (indistinct)
comes in here and also
in terms of the other.
The Haunting of the Present in the Past,
I'll just say Tram Long's chapter
really goes into this into some depth.
A really fascinating chapter,
which talks about the
massacre of the Vietnamese
in the early 70s under Lon Nol.
And these killings were
propagated by the government.
And she chose the juxtaposition
between on the one hand,
this (indistinct) hotel on the
river ways in (indistinct).
Reflecting on the shimmering
surface of the water there.
The (indistinct) hotel is
owned by a Vietnamese tycoon
and that's contrasted
with underneath the waters
is still the bodies of
the hundreds of thousands
of Vietnamese victims that
were killed in the 1970s
that continue to haunt today.
And now with continued ethnic tensions
and racism against the
Vietnamese living in Cambodia,
we can see how that
haunting sits beside that.
So we are out of time.
So that is the organization
of the book and the chapters.
And just to end, we would like to end with
in memory of Benny Widyono,
who gave the first half of
the conference actually.
And unfortunately he passed away
just a couple of months after that.
He would have loved to have been here.
Many of you have met him and knew him.
He in many ways encapsulated
this whole period
that we've been talking about.
He was born and raised in Indonesia,
and he was ethnic Chinese.
He was persecuted for
being ethnic Chinese,
as was his wife Francesca.
Who's in the middle photo there.
He later joined the UN.
He was the Governor of
Siem Reap for the UN,
for UNTAC.
And later became the Special
Representative of the UN
to Cambodia during those years.
And that's him.
We can't see in the picture,
but he's standing there
with King Norodom Sihanouk
and Queen Monique.
And there he is giving
one of his lectures.
So we wanted to take this
moment to remember him.
So I know (indistinct).
Thank you all very much.
(audience clapping)
- For this wonderful talk.
So what we're gonna do
is open it up to Q&A.
Since we have some people on Zoom,
I'm gonna carry the microphone.
If you have a question
just so they'll be able
to ear it properly and
then I'll run back to them.
So bear with me for
that little time delay.
And also I wanna say to
people who are on Zoom,
if you have any questions,
put them in the chat
and Al will flag me and we'll
read the question out loud.
And so we'll get started.
Any questions in the audience?
- [Audience member] Thank you.
And thank you both for the
book and for the presentation.
My question...
Excuse me.
Is something that comes
out of me listening
to the parallels that you both spoke of.
It's the clear and obvious
role that communist parties,
whether as insurgencies or as
political oppositions played.
And I wonder if you can speak to,
is there a comment or parallel
origin of these movements?
Were they trained in China as
the Chinese Communist Party
during the Chinese revolution?
Were they similarly inspired?
was it a training in Europe or was it
each country has a sort of different root.
A different root of communist
opposition and insurgency.
- I'm gonna let you have this one.
- I think that there is a variety
of different kinds of
political inspiration
for the many different and diverse
kinds of political and mass
violence that we cover.
I think some of the most extreme cases
range from the Communist
Party of Kampuchea
and the Pol Pot regime,
to the military dictatorship
in Indonesia, under Suharto,
which was an anticommunist
purge of communists.
Mass murder of communists.
There are cases in between
which perhaps are exemplified
by the Burmese military dictatorship.
Which was inspired by
socialism in one country.
I think they call themselves
the Burmese road to socialism.
But it was definitely
a military dictatorship
and was opposed by the different branches
of the communist party in Burma.
And definitely repressed the...
There are a number of different factions
of Southeast Asian communism.
That took a number of different roads.
That the Malayan Communist
Party was very pro China.
The Vietnamese Communist Party
was more independent of China.
There is a common
chronological theme in 1948,
when many of the communist
parties rose up in rebellion
from Indonesia to Burma to Malaya.
And that was often
thought to have come from
a meeting in Calcutta in 1948.
And it was alleged that
Soviet instructions
or (indistinct) instructions
led to many of the
Southeast Asian communist parties
staging rebellions at the same time.
But there's no consensus on that.
Regional complicity or
regional coordination
amongst historians about that.
I've seen historians debunk that theory.
Although the historical or
chronological concatenation
seems pretty convincing.
But I think what strikes me more
is the across the board violence
that is characteristic of the
Cold War in Southeast Asia.
Other people might disagree,
but it seems to me that there is...
Looking at the violence
in places like Thailand, Burma, Vietnam,
both North and South Indonesia,
the Philippines, Malaysia,
and also the appearance
in all of those places.
Nearly all of them of
democratic potential.
One case that struck me,
just reading this morning,
was in Brunei, which we
don't cover in this book.
The elections that were
held in 1962 for some
only partially democratic participation
of the British were
still the colonial power.
There was the Monarch,
the Sultan of Brunei,
but elections were held for
a representative government
on a partial level.
And the People's Party
Brunei won all 16 seats.
It was a landslide by
representing the popular vote.
And they weren't gonna
get what they wanted.
They didn't get either
full political power
or what they wanted was not
to be included in Malaysia.
And so they chose the
most disastrous option,
which was to revolt.
And they staged a violent revolt
and were crushed by the British.
And Burma is still a
monarchical dictatorship.
So where do we go with that information?
What are the illogical
inspiration to attribute that to?
It seems that there is a
wide range of possibilities
in Southeast Asia.
- We have a question in the chat.
So I'll take that first
in the spirit of inclusion
and I'm gonna read it
because it's difficult for others to see
from the back of the room.
The story Ben Kiernan told about linkages
between violence in Cambodia and Burma,
including the possibility of meetings
between Pol Pot and Ne Win
was absolutely fascinating.
I wonder if you could
explain on the dilemma...
Expand on the dilemma,
these types of cases
present for historian.
On the one hand, the
circumstantial evidence
is too great to ignore, monkey's uncle.
On the other hand, historians
tend not to prize circumstantial evidence
and availability of archival records
is challenging and patchy
at the best at times.
How then should historian
seek to uncover and understand
the hidden circuitry that
linked cases of mass violence.
And that's from Mathias Fibinger.
- Yes, it's quite true that I can't prove
that Pol Pot met with Ne Win
Maybe one day we can check this.
I don't think it's gonna be documented.
It would possibly be documented by now
in the Cambodian records.
It might be documentable
in the Burmese records.
If it occurred.
I just think that it's likely,
but I could be proven wrong.
At any rate four meetings
between Nuon Chea and Ne Win
with Nuon Chea having
been convicted of genocide
against the Cham Muslims.
And Ne Win starting off a
campaign a few months later
of mass persecution of Burma's Muslims,
seems to me to be likely
that they discussed
their common interests in at least
one of those four meetings.
Whether that would leave you to conclude
that there is a linkage
between the two cases
both of which ended up in genocide
in countries that were otherwise unlinked.
Is of course, something
that ought to be explored.
Which is what I'm saying.
That's the reference
to the monkey's uncle.
But I think that Katherine
Munyan is quite right
in her chapter, that there
were opportunities missed
by service of the
Burmese case to point out
the strong likelihood of
this Rohingya genocide
adventure bagging.
Not necessarily just on the basis
of Ne Win's visit to Cambodia,
but on the point she makes about intent
and the evidence that existed over decades
of persecution, of the Rohingya.
That nonjudicial
organizations as she puts it,
could have called for an investigation
into whether a genocide
is ongoing or likely
earlier than they did.
And I think she's right about that.
- (indistinct) your hand was up.
Maybe you can also tell
everyone who you are
since it's the first time
to be in person for you.
- [Audience member] Thank you.
My name is (indistinct)
and I'm a (indistinct)
of social studies.
So I'm very excited and
finally to be here in person
and meet everyone.
So, one thing that I really
appreciate is the connections
precisely that you pointed out.
Despite the diversity of the region.
Now, what I'm interested in is
the opposite, in the center.
Now give them this commonalities.
If you haven't had the
chance to read the book,
but clearly the many
episodes of mass violence
that the book has covered,
there is a range in terms of
perhaps degree of violence,
causes of violence,
how violence perpetrated so forth.
So an example, you gave is Khmer Rouge,
Killing in Khmer Rouge.
The degree of violence
there is for instance
certainly not the same as perhaps
violence occurring under the Huk Rebellion
in the Philippines.
So there's a range there.
So I'm interested from your perspective,
and your understanding,
what might be the positive
factors that explain why
in some cases there can
be perhaps more restrained
or more factor to prevent
violence from escalating,
for instance to the extent
like Khmer Rouge and so forth.
So I wanna explain variation
in contrast and the commonalities.
Thank you.
- Thank you for your wonderful question.
And it's really an excellent point.
There is clearly a very large range
in the various different
cases covered in the books
and cases also beyond the book.
In terms of degree and scale
and causes and so forth.
And, that's one of the
things with taking on
a big topic of political
violence in Southeast Asia
and across really different regions
and not even all exactly
in the same time period.
That there are lots of different factors.
Both in terms of global factors
of the global politics that are going on.
And also in terms of local politics
and local culture as well.
I think that apart from the
large thematic commonalities,
for example, The Cold
War you had for example,
aerial bombing in Cambodia.
You had aerial bombing in
Laos and Vietnam as well.
You still had within that same Cold War,
you didn't have that same...
Well, it played out in
other parts of the region,
for example, in Indonesia,
there was no aerial bombing there.
Why?
Well, for one thing, there
was not an external source
that's coming in with these
airplanes doing the bombing.
Even though there was also bombing,
within those countries as well.
But the type of violence
and the types of targets
that was happening
was different in Indonesia.
Mass killings in both cases.
But they weren't trying to...
Some of the aims of the regime itself
and the ideologies of the
regimes were quite different.
And there was of course, external players
in the Indonesian case as well.
For example, you have the British,
as it's been in all
the headlines recently.
Through the release of
the various documents
that had been released that
talk about their part in that.
And there were certainly
the US role to play there.
But it was secretive in
that case where it was over
or in Vietnam.
So I think that it's a very
large question that you ask
and there's lots of differences,
even in cases that may
happen at the same time,
or even with some of the same players.
But yeah, I think I'll stop there
because it's a big question.
- I'm gonna take one last
question for sake of time
and I see that (indistinct)
has a question also.
If you can introduce
yourself (indistinct).
- Hi, thank you very much for your book.
and your fascinating presentation.
My name is (indistinct)
and I am also a postdoc
from Southeast Asian studies,
also on South East Asian Studies.
And I have a really quick question.
Based on what you have
presented and new question,
I'm wondering about the methodologies.
About, across the chapters and authors
and when they write
about their case studies.
Because I think Ben mentioned that
there are some case studies un-observable,
and I believe that there's many cases.
In terms of the documents, the recording,
he says something is missing there.
And then you also highlight the cases here
in South Asian countries.
So I'm wondering which methods could work.
And in this particular cases,
and in this particular area.
From here to when they do
in a Holocaust, for example.
Or they do other mass
violence in other places.
And then how the area (indistinct)
something more particularly
in the way that you authors
conduct their research.
- Okay, I'll be brief.
The collection and the volume is by...
It's not only different countries,
but it's also the authors
of the various chapters
are coming from different disciplines.
So they're using different
approaches to do the research.
Sometimes with what...
Although they overlap quite a bit as well.
But there is interviews.
Some relying more on interviews,
some where on archival documents.
But it does to some extent
depend on the country
and what's available in
terms of the archives either.
And who it's possible to interview.
And that also is a factor of time.
If it's something that
occurred a while ago,
those people may not be
directly available to interview.
Where if it's something fairly recent,
you can take either
likely more interviews,
but less archival resources.
So I'm just going to
let Ben add onto that.
- I think one of the gaps
that I think we could
have filled, but didn't
was East Timor.
I think that's one of the
major cases of mass violence
that we didn't cover.
But there are others as well.
We just obviously
couldn't cover everything.
But on the different question
of why some cases of mass
violence occur and others don't
and why some regimes or
parties or individuals
are more restrained than others.
Come back to the question
of long-term causes
of mass violence or genocide.
And the immediate ones.
Suddenly there's parties of institutions
or leaders of institutions
do make decisions that are
going to escalate violence.
Jeffrey Robinson talks
about this in his chapter,
quite illuminatingly.
That it's not just the ethnic conflict
or these clash of civilizations
as Samuel Huntington put it.
Or the fact of migration or war, poverty,
economic destabilization.
These long-term factors can exist.
But for a major crisis
to turn into a genocide
or extermination or other
crimes against humanity,
it still requires a decision
by a group of perpetrators
to take advantage of that opportunity.
To enforce or impose a
campaign of mass murder.
And some leaders don't do that.
They refrain from doing it.
And I think they may commit violence.
They may repress opposition parties.
They may put people in jail,
but they may not commit mass violence.
Others too, and we've seen
that across the spectrum
that does happen, but in
some cases it doesn't happen.
And I think to look at the
immediate cause of the genocide,
we have to look at
political decision-making.
And sometimes that's informed by ideology.
And sometimes it's informed by political
or human decisions that
relate to the nature
of the personality or the
group around the person.
Or the group of people who decided
to kill a lot of people
rather than accept less power.
I think that's an
important factor as well.
The immediate causes of mass murder.
It's political decisions.
- I just wanna say
thank you to Ben and Eve
for a fascinating discussion.
A wonderful way to start our
return to hybrid normalcy.
If there's such a thing
as hybrid normal normalcy.
Please join me in thanking them.
(audience clapping)
And remember, next week
we have Helena Leslie,
who will in some ways,
carry on the conversation
into the present day.
So it'd be really great continuity.
So thanks everyone.
Bye bye.